Ich würde gerne das erste Gespräch mit Ihnen führen. Ist das in Ordnung für Sie?
Ja, Frau Durtr.
Okay. Zuerst werde ich Ihnen ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen.
Dann können wir Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden überlegen.
Und darf ich Sie um Ihren Namen bitten?
Ja, Klaus Huber. Mein Name ist Klaus Huber.
Klaus, können Sie Ihren Vornamen beschreiben?
Ja, Klaus, K-L-A-U-S, Huber, H-U-B-E-R.
Okay. Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Huber?
Ich bin 33, Frau Doktor.
33. Okay. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
1. April 1992.
Okay. Wissen Sie, wie groß Sie sind?
Ja, ich bin 1 Meter 79.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich wiege ungefähr 65 Kilogramm.
65. Okay. Wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt oder Ihre Hausärztin?
Ja, meine Hausärztin heißt Frau Steffi Graf.
Steffi Graf?
Ja, Graf. Frau Graf.
Frau Graf. Okay. Mit Double F oder eine F?
Ja, Double F. G-A-M-R-G-R-A-Double F.
Okay. Danke schön, Frau Huber, für diese Informationen.
Und was für Sie heute so?
Frau Doktor, ehrlich zu sagen, habe ich seit drei Monaten Beschwerden.
Und meine Beschwerden sind verlafft, seit verschlimmert.
Ich fühle meinen linken Bein schwach.
Ich kann zur Zeit nicht gut laufen.
In der letzten Zeit humpere ich.
Und in den zweiten zwei Wochen stolpere ich sehr oft.
Und zweimal bin ich gestürzt.
Okay. Sie haben seit drei Monaten Bein schwach.
Und in den zweiten zwei Wochen stolpert sie sich.
Hat sie stolpert haben? Und?
Ja, ich humpere auch.
Ich stolpere und habe zweimal gestürzt.
Gefallen.
Gefallen, okay.
Das gefällt mir nicht. Ich bin jung und ich bin sehr aktiv normalerweise.
Aber ich kann nicht gut laufen. Das stört mir.
Okay. Aber Sie haben seit drei Monaten keine Beschwerden.
Nein, nein. Ich war sehr sportlich, Frau Doktor.
Ich bin sehr jung.
Aber in den letzten drei Monaten möchte ich nicht rausgehen.
Das ist immer schlimm geworden.
Okay. Haben Sie diese Schwache mit beiden Beinen?
Nein, linke Seite.
Okay, linke Beine.
Haben Sie Tapshaltgefühl? Oder fühlen Sie sich kribbeln?
Ja, auf dem linken Bein wie eine Ameise laufen.
Ich fühle das ist wie komische Gefühl.
Taubeizgefühl oder Kribbeln. Ich kann nicht gut beschreiben.
Okay.
Könnten Sie Ihren linken Bein abholen?
Ja, ich kann.
Okay.
Schmerzen?
Schmerzen ist nicht schlimm. Aber manchmal fühle ich Schmerzen im linken Bein.
Okay.
Haben Sie an den Beinen Gerotet, Schwellung oder Überwärm bemerkt?
Nein, das ist ganz normal.
Ganz normal, aber ich fühle es dünner als rechte Seite.
Ich fühle es ein bisschen dünner als rechte Seite.
Ich erinnere mich daran, dass ich vor drei Monaten meine Beschwerden gestiegen habe.
Es war schwer, die Treppe zu steigen und meine Beschwerden zu beginnen.
Okay, Ihre Beschwerden sind langsam aufgetreten, aber in Verlauf sind sie nicht.
Ja, ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Grundscher-Krankungen?
Nein, Doktor. Ich war ganz gesund.
Vor zwei Monaten.
Okay.
Haben Sie in Ihrer Familie oder Umgebung eine Person mit 50 Beschwerden?
Nein, ich erinnere mich nicht. Mein Vater ist ganz gesund jetzt auch.
Aber meine Mutter leidet an Mama-Karzinom.
Mama-Karzinom.
Ich fühle mich sehr müde, Frau Doktor. Ich möchte nichts machen.
Ich möchte nicht rausgehen. Es geht immer schlimmer.
Sie können das verstehen. Das ist sehr schwer für einen Jungmann.
Okay, das ist eine schwierige Situation. Ich verstehe ganz genau.
Haben Sie Atemnot?
Nein, nein. Ich kann gut atmen.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein, ich habe keine Fieber.
Okay. Haben Sie Nachschweiß?
Nein, nein. Ich habe keine Nachschweiß.
Haben Sie in den letzten sechs Monaten ungewöhnlich ab- oder zugenommen?
Nein, ich bin immer für 65 ungefähr.
Okay. Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Nein, mir ist nicht schwindelig.
Okay. Haben Sie Öbigkeit oder Emesis?
Nein, vor einem Monat hatte ich einmal erbrochen.
Aber ich habe gedacht, dass ich etwas gegessen habe. Deswegen hatte ich erbrochen.
Okay.
Wenn Sie gefällt haben, sind Sie auf den fünften Fall gefallen?
Nicht gefällt. Ich bin hingefallen, aber ich hatte keine Verletzung.
Keine Verletzung.
Nur zwei Fallen. Natürlich tut es weh, aber ich habe keine Verletzung.
Haben Sie mit Ihren Armen 55 werden?
Nein, nein.
Nein, nur die linke Fahne habe ich mit.
Okay.
Aber Frau Doktor, ich hatte vor zwei Monaten einmal 15 Minuten doppel gezergen.
Ich habe gewartet, ich könnte nicht einen Termin finden.
Ich habe gewartet, dann sei ich ganz normal. Das war nur einmal.
Okay. Haben Sie auch Hörschüttungen?
Hörschüttungen habe ich nicht.
Nicht. Okay. Ja, ich verstehe.
Könnten Sie Ihren Surin bis zur Toilette erhalten?
Ja, ich habe keine Probleme.
Okay. Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Nein, ich habe manchmal Verstopfungen, aber das ist seit ich Kind war. Das ist lange Geschichte.
Okay. Wann war Ihr letztes Stuhl?
Ich war gestern beim Stuhlgang.
Okay. Rachen Sie?
Ich rache nicht. Nein. Ich hasse Zigaretten.
Okay. Sie rachen nicht?
Ja, ich rache nicht.
Okay. Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke gelegentlich. Besonders am Wochenende. Aber in den letzten drei Monaten möchte ich nicht trinken.
Und möchte ich nicht mit meinen Freunden treffen.
Also trinke ich nicht.
Okay. Am Wochenende trinken Sie... Wie trinken Sie?
Bier trinke ich. Ich trinke normalerweise gerne Bier, aber in den letzten zwei Monaten trinke ich nicht.
Okay. Hatten Sie jemals mit Drogen Kontakt?
Nein, nein. Habe ich keinen Kontakt mit Drogen.
Okay. Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich bin ein Einzelkind.
Okay. Würden Sie schon mal operiert?
Ja, als ich Kind war, wurde mein Bildarm entfernt.
Okay. War diese Operation komplikationlos?
Nein, ich erinnere mich nicht an die Komplikation.
Okay. Haben Sie noch andere Operationen?
Nein, habe ich keine Operationen.
Trinken Sie regelmäßig Medikamente ein?
Ja, wenn ich Alergie habe, nehme ich Spray.
Manchmal habe ich besonders Alergie im Frühling.
Und manchmal trinke ich und dann nehme ich einen Spray.
Okay. Ist das eine Alergie?
Ja, das ist vielleicht eine Polyallergie.
Aber das ist ein Frühling.
Okay. Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, ich bin vollständig geimpft.
Trinken Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Ja.
Seit drei Monaten?
Ja, ja. Ich habe sehr oft Fußball gespielt, gelaufen.
Aber seit drei Monaten kann ich nicht Sport treiben.
Okay. Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Informatiker.
Haben Sie viel Stress in der Arbeit?
Ja, meine Arbeit ist sehr stressig.
Okay. Sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein, ich bin leid.
Okay. Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein, ich habe keine Kinder.
Ich fühle mich sehr isoliert und einsam, Frau Doktor.
Mein Leben ist sehr langweilig für mich.
Besonders seit drei Monaten.
Okay. Ich verstehe Sie.
Ich werde Ihnen schnell helfen.
Bitte machen Sie sich keine Sorgen.
Ich glaube, wir können Ihre gut behandeln.
Okay. Ich habe alle meine Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Frau Doktor, ich habe Angst.
Ich bin jung und kann nicht gut bewegen.
Was kann ich tun?
Ich kann nicht bewegen.
Frau Huba, Sie können viele Ursachen haben.
Um eine deutliche Diagnose zu stellen,
möchten wir einige Untersuchungen durchführen.
Ich möchte Sie auf die Beispiele des Bundeskanzlers
ein Problem haben.
Sie haben ein Problem mit Ihrem Nervensystem.
Nervensystem.
Aber ...
Sie können etwas hinzufügen.
Ja, ich denke ...
Aber warum?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Warum?
Ich bin sehr jung.
Normalerweise hat ein Mensch eine neurologische Krankheit.
Warum habe ich ...
Ich verstehe Sie.
Warum können wir nicht eine genaue ...
... sagen?
Aber ...
Ich möchte Sie ...
... eine genaue Diagnose stellen.
Eine genaue Diagnose stellen.
Ich werde Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Dann Blut abnehmen.
Und einige weitere Untersuchungen durchführen.
Ich werde Ihnen eine Röntgenaufnahme vornehmen.
Dann eine MRI oder CT oder gegebenenfalls eine MRI durchführen.
Und Ihre Beschwerden werde ich meinen Oberarzt besprechen.
Wenn ich alle Ergebnisse halte,
werde ich Sie informieren.
Was ist MRT, Frau Doktorin? Ich habe nicht gehört.
Erstmal.
MRT ist eine Abkursung für ...
... Magnetikresonanz.
Ja, klar.
Magnetresonanz-Tomographie.
Das ist eine Schmerz-Fri-Untersuchung.
Und mit Hilfe dieser Untersuchung beurteilen wir Ihre ganze Körper.
Deshalb denke ich, diese Untersuchung ist notwendig für Sie.
Sie müssen liegen.
Sie liegen rückenlage und einige Maschine.
Ihre Körper ...
Sie müssen liegen.
Und wir geben mit Hilfe von MRT einige Bilder von Ihren Körpern.
Diese Untersuchung dauert ca. 15 Minuten.
Und ...
Okay, Frau Doktorin. Ich bin nicht da.
Ich habe diese Aufgaben nicht gearbeitet.
Herr Oberarzt, ich möchte Ihnen einen neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Haben Sie Zeit für mich?
Ja, natürlich. Bitte schön.
Der Patient heißt Klaas Huber.
Er ist 33 Jahre alt.
Er ist 1,79 Meter groß und 65 Kilogramm schwer.
Hür Huber stellte sich heute bei uns.
Er stellt sich seit drei Monaten mit seiner linken Beine.
Seine linkseitigen Beine.
Oder ... ja.
Der Patient stellt sich heute bei uns wegen seit drei Monaten bestehender,
linkseitiger,
kraftlos und ...
Meinen Sie Parasit?
Ja, Parasit.
Und der Patient klagt über auf ...
Parasit, Hypostasie ...
Nein, Hypestasie.
Okay, Hypestasie.
Hypestasie und Fatigue.
Fatigue.
Diese Beschwerden sind langsam aufgetreten.
Nach der Belastung steigen besonders Treppe auf.
Ja.
Nein.
Okay.
Was ist da?
Diese Beschwerden ...
Okay.
Diese Beschwerden sind langsam aufgetreten.
Der Patient berichtet ...
Der Patient berichtet die Schmerzen.
Oder der Patient beschreibt ...
Der Patient beschreibt ...
Der Patient beschreibt, diese Beschwerden belasten die Schmerzen.
Erstmal belasten die Schmerzen.
Also meinen Sie Parasit oder?
Ja.
Okay.
Es gibt keine Routinen, keine Farben, Dämonen oder Tumoren am linken Bein.
Und die vegetative Anamnese ...
Moment mal.
Was ist das, dass die Beschwerden blindert oder verschlimmert?
Habe ich Sie schon gefragt?
Gibt es ... Nein.
Ich habe nicht gefragt, aber ich werde bei den Untersuchungen diese Fragen stellen.
Aber diese Fragen stellen ...
Diese Beschwerden sind langsam aufgetreten, aber im Verlauf sind sie schlimmer geworden.
Der Patient hat keine anderen Schmerzen.
Gibt es Schmerzen bei diesem Patienten oder?
Nein.
Keine Schmerzen?
Der Patient hat keine Schmerzen.
Sie haben nur eine Beschwerde beim linken Bein.
Und in drei Monaten haben sie viele Stolperungen.
Okay.
Leidet der Patient irgendwelche neurologischen Probleme?
In drei Monaten hat er eine Zähne-Störung wie eine Doppelzähne.
Aber er hat keine anderen neurologischen Symptome.
Sie haben keine Zähne-Störung oder Schmerzen oder Schmerzenprobleme.
Sie können ihre Übrigen erhalten.
Sie haben keine Unkontinenten.
Genau.
Okay?
Okay.
Was machen Sie weiter?
Sie haben keine Unkontinenten.
Okay.
Und was haben Sie bei der Vekatativanamnese?
In der Vekatativanamnese war es unaufällig.
Die Vekatativanamnese war unaufällig bis auf inapathens.
Ich habe die Schlafstörung nicht gefragt.
Inapathens und Schlafstörung.
Aber der Patient berichtet über, dass sie keine Lust haben.
Der Patient versucht, zu Hause zu bleiben.
Er hat seine Beschwerden.
Er kann nicht gut laufen.
Er hat seine Bewegung eingeschränkt.
Deshalb hat er auch psychologische Störungen.
Er fühlt sich langweilig.
Können Sie mir sagen, leidet der Patient unter depressiver Verstimmung?
Ja, ein bisschen.
Er hat einige depressive Symptome.
Hat er ein Selbstmordgedanken?
Nein, ich habe ihn nicht gefragt.
Aber der Patient hat seine Beschwerden nur drei Monate.
Er möchte die Behandlung behandeln.
Deshalb denke ich, dass er nicht etwas Schöneres denkt.
An Erkrankungen.
Der Patient hat keine bekannten Erkrankungen.
Er nimmt keine regelmäßigen Medikamente.
Aber er hat eine Fühlingalergie.
Deshalb nimmt er bei Bedarf Spray ein.
Er ist ledig und hat keine Kinder.
Er arbeitet als Informatiker.
Mit wem wohnt er?
Er ist ledig und lebt alleine.
Alleine, okay.
Was haben wir über die Voroperation?
Als Kind wurde bei dem Patienten eine Apendoktome durchgeführt.
Sie hatte keine anderen Operationen.
In der Familienanalyse wird bei der Mutter angegeben,
dass Mama Karsinon vorliegt.
Sein Vater ist gesund.
Er hat keine Geschwister.
Er ist nicht rauhier und trinkt gelegentlich Alkohol.
Aber seit drei Monaten, wenn seine Beschwerden aufgetreten sind,
trinkt er keinen Alkohol.
Die Drogenkonsumung wurde verneilt.
An anonystischen Angaben
wird am ersten Mal eine Multiple Sclerose verwendet.
Welche Symptome sprechen für eine Multiple Sclerose?
Ich habe einseitige Hypesthesie.
Er ist 33 Jahre alt.
Er ist ein junger Patient.
Ich habe früher keine Beschwerden.
Sie haben keine Fieber oder keinen Unfall.
Er hat keine Unfall oder andere Erkrankungen.
Er hat Multiple Sclerose.
Welche Differential Diagnose?
Das ist eine Diskushernie.
Das ist ein Lendenbereich.
Welche Symptome sprechen gegen eine Diskuspolapsus?
Der Patient hat keine Ursache für eine Diskushernie.
Es gibt keine bestimmten Auslöser?
Keine Auslöser.
Sonst noch?
Also keine Schmerzen?
Ja, keine Schmerzen.
Sie haben eine Parasthesie und Hypostese,
aber keine Inkontinenz.
Deshalb denke ich,
diese Beschwerden sprechen für einen Lendenbereich oder Lendenwirbelsäule.
Okay, sonst noch?
Etwas als Differential Diagnose?
Ja, als Differential Diagnose, PAVK,
kommen in Betracht.
Kommt Apoplex bei diesem Patienten als Differential Diagnose?
Apoplex, ja.
Wir denken, Apoplex.
Warum?
Wenn man eine Apoplex hat,
kann man eine 50-5-Wertige haben.
Eine Subarachnoidal-Bolutung oder TA.
Nein.
Warum nicht? Okay.
Nach dem TA.
Man kann diese Beschwerden,
aber im Verlauf der Beschwerden des Patienten
schlimmer geworden sind.
Deshalb ist das nicht ein temporäres Thema.
Die Patientin hat diese Beschwerden seit drei Monaten.
Diese Zeit ist relativ lange.
Okay, jetzt haben Sie eine Verdachtdiagnose
und Sie haben auch viele verschiedene Differential Diagnose.
Was machen Sie jetzt?
Zur Abklarung der Beschwerden
sollten wir weitere Untersuchungen durchführen.
Zuerst würde ich körperliche Untersuchungen.
Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Neurologische Untersuchungen sind notwendig.
Ich inspiziere alle Körper.
Ich überprüfe die Muskeln.
Muskeln? Okay.
Muskeln und ...
Muskeln, ja.
Muskeln.
Ich überprüfe Muskeln, Kraft oder Sensibilität.
Motorik oder Sensorik?
Störungen.
Okay.
Noch?
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung.
Ich abtaste beide Beine.
Und ich taste beide Beine ab.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie eine Differential Diagnose haben.
Also PAVK.
Was machen Sie?
Ich beurteile den linken Bein über Rotung, Schwellung oder Überwärmung.
Aber der Patient hat gesagt, dass er keine Differential Diagnose hat.
Also P4-Pulse. Das ist sehr wichtig.
Genau.
Okay. Und was machen Sie als Apparativdiagnostik?
Um Ihre Verdacht Diagnose zu bestätigen.
Ja, für diesen Fall sollte sich die Verdacht Diagnose zur Abklärung der Beschwerden ...
... würde ich ein MRT verlassen.
Was erwarten Sie bei dieser Untersuchung?
Ich meine MRT.
Ein MRT ...
Ich weiß nicht, was ich sehe.
Ich denke, es ist ein Plak für MRT.
Ich bin mir sicher, dass es ein neuer Fall ist.
Aber die Plak sind sehr wichtig.
Ja, ein MRT. Und ein Schädel-MRT ist wichtig.
Nach dem MRT würde ich eine Lumbar-Funktion führen.
Bei der Lumbar-Funktion überprüfe ich oder bei der Lumbar-Funktion zeigt uns Antikörper.
Aber welche Antikörper? Ich weiß nicht.
Okay.
Und ein EG könnte die Muskelzustand beurteilen.
Zustand meinen Sie?
Ja, Muskelzustand.
EG meinen Sie, oder?
EG.
Okay.
Sie haben schon Ihre Verdacht Diagnose bestätigt.
Was machen Sie jetzt als Therapie?
Welche Möglichkeiten haben wir?
Sollte sich die Verdacht Diagnose bestätigen, schlage ich die vorgängigen Therapien vor.
Zuerst Glykokortikoid und einige Immunsuppressivtherapien.
Und diese Patienten oder Multiple Sclerosis sind eine chronische Erkrankung.
Und im Verlauf ist diese Krankheit verschlechtert.
Deshalb empfehle ich die Patienten regelmäßig zum Arzt gehen.
Okay.
Wir würden ein neurologisches Konzept anfordern, um die Therapie des Patienten zu optimieren.
Okay, gut.
Okay.